مرحله حساسه اذا يعيشها العالم وليست
روسيا وحدها غولوا التضخم استيقظ للتو
فسنعود الى المئه وعشرين مليون برميل من
الديزل التي استوردتها استوردها الاتحاد
الاوروبي من روسيا ماذا تمثل هذه الكميه
14 الف حوض سباحه اولمبي في هذه الكميات
استمراريه حياه على الاقل لاوروبا الديزل
الضروري للزراعه لا تحتمل المزيد من
التعقيدات بعد فصل جاف والديزل ايضا اساسي
للنقل البري الذي شحت عمليات الاستيراد من
خلاله لجلب مستلزمات الغذاء على مدى عام
كامل من الحرب ولان كل ما نستخدمه من
منتجات يتم شحنها في شاحنات او ناقلات
بالديزل فبالتالي الشحن البحري ايضا مهدد
وذلك بسبب ماده النفته التي تدخل في صناعه
البنزين والبلاستيك وزيت الوقود استهلك
ايضا في توليد الطاقه من كل هذه القطاعات
تستحوذ روسيا روسيا على اكثر من 9% لشحنات
المنتجات النفطيه العالميه